el resultado del que espero darle un
poco de intuición es uno que vamos a
utilizar después para una demostración
de la regla de la cadena y digo una
demostración porque puede que haya
varias demostraciones de ella así que
este resultado dice que si tenemos
nosotros una función de x que es
continua en un punto c continua en x
igual hace muy bien entonces esto nos va
a implicar que el cambio en un tenderá a
cero cuando el cambio en x tiende a cero
y por supuesto este cambio en x debe ser
alrededor de c muy bien entonces quizás
lo que valdría la pena es recordar que
significa que una función sea continua
en un punto x igual a 0 y eso lo vimos
incluso o lo repasamos en el vídeo donde
demostramos que la deriva bilidad
implica
la continuidad muy bien pero esto
simplemente vamos a repasar lo esto nos
dice que el límite cuando x tiende a c
dvd x es igual a lo que esperamos verdad
evaluar y en el punto c muy bien y por
supuesto esto lo único que nos está
diciendo es que no tenemos saltos en la
gráfica o que no tenemos agujeros verdad
y de hecho lo hemos visto ya en otros
vídeos así que en este momento lo que
vamos a hacer es manipular esta
expresión algebraica mente y algo que
hay que notar antes de continuar con
todos nuestros argumentos es que udc es
un valor fijo verdad u desea lo mejor no
se puede ser 5 o 100 opi o puede ser lo
que ustedes a lo mejor puedan imaginarse
pero lo importante es que esto ya es un
valor fijo esto ya no depende de la x
muy bien así que vamos a calcular o
vamos a manipular algebraica mente esto
simplemente podemos pasar restando el
udc verdad entonces tendríamos que el
límite cuando x tiende a c de de x menos
udc esto es
igual a 0 verdad y esto lo podemos meter
todo en un solo límite porque justamente
ud se es una constante y el límite de
una constante es la misma constante de
hecho esto lo vimos en el vídeo donde
demostramos que la deriva bilidad
implica la continuidad verdad
simplemente observamos que pues que si x
tiende a ser de x tenderá a udc por ser
continua y entonces udc menos udc nos
daría a 0 verdad entonces esto solo es
un breve repaso de lo que ya hemos
estado viendo aunque entonces esta
expresión que acabamos de obtener es lo
que nos dará la esencia de lo que
queremos probar verdad que el cambio no
tenderá a cero y para eso valdría la
pena hacer un buen dibujo digamos que
aquí tenemos nuestro eje u y aquí
tenemos nuestro eje x y digamos que
nuestra función se ve algo
así muy bien entonces no sé tomémonos
algún punto que digamos que este es el
punto ce y pues por supuesto por acá
andará el valor
dc muy bien ahora si nos tomamos un
punto x digamos este punto x entonces el
valor de la función o evaluado en el
punto x estará por aquí verdad
corresponde a ese punto y a partir de
esta imagen podríamos ir observando
algunas cosas por ejemplo el cambio en
un lo podríamos ver justo como esta
altura esta misma altura es lo que
podemos ver como el cambio en un
entonces si nosotros definimos el cambio
en y como pude x menos udc es justamente
lo que hemos rayado aquí con verde cuál
sería entonces el cambio en x pues sería
justamente esto que tenemos aquí verdad
la diferencia que hay de x ac entonces
el cambio en x es igual a x menos c
verdad entonces observemos lo siguiente
cuando x se aproxima hace el cambio en x
se aproxima a 0
así que esta expresión que nosotros
teníamos acá arriba lo podríamos
reescribir de la siguiente forma el
límite del cuando el cambio en x tiende
a 0 verdad porque cuando x tiende a c
pues el cambio en x tiende a 0 de
nuestro cambio en que es justamente lo
que tenemos en este paréntesis será
igual a 0 verdad simplemente
reescribimos este último límite y por
supuesto lo que nos está diciendo aquí
es justamente verdad cuando el cambio en
x tiende a 0 entonces el cambio en uno
tiende también a cero verdad y es
justamente lo que queríamos demostrar
era lo que teníamos acá arriba con
amarillo verdad y en cierto sentido uno
podría pensar que es algo de sentido
común verdad para las funciones
continuas verdad si nuestro cambio en x
está aquí medido esto es el cambio en xy
cuando lo hacemos tender
entonces el cambio en la función verdad
irá disminuyendo disminuyendo hasta
atender al valor o más bien la función
tendrá el valor udc y eso hace que el
cambio se entienda a cero así que espero
que te haya gustado esta exposición
porque además lo vamos a utilizar para
demostrar la regla de la cadena en el
siguiente vídeo